vamos bienvenidos a francia 24 hoy la
entrevistamos a ofelia fernández ella es
la legisladora más joven de toda américa
latina tiene 20 años y se volvió una
referente de la lucha para el derecho al
aborto en su país argentina que está a
punto de votar una ley que legalizaría
ofelia está considerada persona de
riesgo durante la pandemia y entonces
nos recibe virtualmente en su
departamento de buenos aires donde está
confinada
hola ofelia hola que tal buzz empezaste
de interesarte en la política muy joven
a los 11 años a los 15 ya eras la
presidenta más joven de la historia del
centro de estudiantes del prestigioso
colegio carlos pellegrini en buenos
aires y a los 19 años te convertiste en
la diputada de la ciudad de buenos aires
entonces en dónde nació y cómo se
alimentó tu pasión por lo político va a
sonar un poco cliché pero digo cuando
son niña tal vez como cruzarte con
ciertas asimetrías de la realidad tiene
un impacto particular tengo como mucho
la imagen sobre todo con la problemática
de situación de calle etcétera de no
terminar de comprender dónde estaba él
dónde estaba la razón de que yo voy a
construir mi vida en una casa comiendo
etcétera y otras personas no dio desde a
él desde esa cosa tan elemental o
instintiva de preguntarse qué que había
detrás de la realidad como la conocemos
pero lo que cuando se volvió potente ese
compromiso fue cuando tener el colegio y
descubrí que te contaba con una
herramienta para organizar esas ideas
para darle para conocer la historia que
hacía a mi contexto particularmente y
empezar a tener compañeros y compañeras
que para mí es es fundacional en el cual
uno uno empieza a pasar de tener interés
o estar politizados
a militar a ser parte activa de la
transformación de la realidad entonces
teniendo en cuenta que mi escuela tiene
un centro de estudiantes de larga
historia apenas entré ya eso estaba muy
articulado y pude pude adentrarme
fácilmente
la temática del feminismo cuando se
empezó a interesar es muy interesante
porque soriana tenía dos años o tres de
militante y sin pensar en transfer
ministra sin sentir prioridades agenda o
incluso sin conocerla y abruptamente en
2015 cuando en argentina se organiza la
primera marcha en una menos como un
grito una condesa o por una constancia
entre en los femicidios en esa
movilización que de repente fue
completamente masiva y que logró
conmocionar nos como a niveles que no
esperábamos fue muy loco como de repente
mi agenda desde ese momento cambió por
completo es decir si esa tenía
articulada buena parte de mis
convicciones que me estaba acostumbrada
a oscilar en ciertos planos
reivindicaciones lo educativos en el
tanah los derechos humanos es decir
tenía ya toda una configuración y
repentinamente no solo
incorpora dos nuevos puntos sino que el
feminismo es una perspectiva entonces
tuve que revisar incluso cómo comprendía
las prioridades y las lógicas de la
militancia en sí pero también de las
otras consignas que veníamos llevando
adelante porque ser feministas en
definitiva estar del lado de la historia
de cómo sería en esa plaza y de las
plazas que iban a seguir de ahí en
adelante en tu caso es emblemático de lo
que acá se llamó la revolución de las
pibas la revolución de las cejas nos
puedes contar un poquito de esta
movilización muy fuerte en las jornadas
de la lucha por el aborto nos dimos
cuenta de que las móviles las móviles no
el cuerpo a la movilización eran esas
columnas de jóvenes y sus centros de
estudiantes de esos jóvenes sueltos
sueltas que tal vez incluso muchos casos
por primera vez llevando una marcha por
primera vez
y se adentraba en una causa y por
primera en su símbolo como lo era el
pañuelo la revolución de las hijas
representa es una manera de reconocer la
potencia y centralidad de la juventud en
la lucha feminista hoy pero
comprendiendo que la historia no empieza
cuando entramos sino que por el
contrario es la persistencia de las
contratadas de marginales o de agendas
de segunda siguieron adelante siguieron
intentando y en definitiva construyeron
la fuerza y las herramientas para que
entre otras nos hagamos para entonces
para mí es hermoso porque muestra si
bien pone el acento en las nuevas
generaciones muestra lo interés en el
asunto del feminismo y en el marco de
esta lucha feminista por qué es tan
importante legalizar el aborto y
terminar con el aborto clandestino es un
derecho tal que además es muy comprende
mucho más que el mero derecho al aborto
o al menos en argentina se construyó la
pelea por el aborto con una integralidad
que es el puntapié además muchas otras
conquistas que van a seguir digo por qué
la pelea por el corto legal
es pedagógica en tanto nos hace nos hace
salir de la lógica biologicista porque
no sólo hay mujeres pero digamos no hay
pensar en clave de personas restantes
esta lógica tanto hablamos de que el
aborto clandestino mata la que no tienen
recursos es decir en la anunciación a
favor del aborto hay también un de una
habitación o una apuesta
una puesta en valor de esa desigualdad
social de fondo en la pelea por el
aborto aparece aparece la puesta
educativa delante de la educación sexual
integral para transformarnos en el
consentimiento en el placer en el deseo
este proyecto de ley era una promesa de
campaña del presidente de alberto
fernández cuyo espacio político
compartir hubiese tenido que tratarse a
mitad de marzo pero con la pandemia fue
demorado pero cuando volvió a la semi
normalidad acá
no estaba más el proyecto en la agenda
legislativa y fue necesaria la gran
movilización de las organizaciones
feministas para recordarle su promesa al
presidente no fuiste una de las pocas
voces adentro del partido que se alzó
para poner presión públicamente entonces
la pregunta es en el perú mismo cuyo
máximo valor es la lealtad y aparte
siendo tan joven
muy fácil expresar una voz disidente y
crítica
y la clara incluso lealtad me parece
hermosa pero creo que es imposible
practicar lealtades individuales o
bilaterales si no tenemos la convicción
yo creo que hay que ser coherentes en
ese sentido entonces no pude evitarlo
porque además
pero todo digamos esté cubierto entonces
ya está más exigente más riguroso porque
también las excusas que iban apareciendo
era muy interesante para mí escuchar
porque eran muy tramas cosas es decir no
es un momento en el que generar
discordia bueno siempre va a generar de
boyá y ningún derecho de estas
características se conquistó intentando
moderar esa tensión por el contrario se
necesitó la valentía de jugársela y
posesión está previamente por la
ampliación de derechos no podía no alzar
la voz al cafeto y sabía que podían
comprar que eran capaces de comer caro
por eso lo estamos de tu pierna porque
crees que la argentina siendo tan
liberal en otras cuestiones sociales
tiene por ejemplo un marco legal
vanguardista en las cuestiones el gp y
tiene también una ley de género que ya
tiene 8 años pero que sigue siendo un
de las más liberales del mundo porque en
tantas argentinas se resiste tanto a
legalizar el aborto recordemos que hace
dos años un proyecto similar fue
rechazado por el senado
los movimientos reaccionarios como tal
tienen o tienen como condición intentar
generar contrapeso y fue estar la fuerza
que ganó la pelea por el aborto es tan
grande la expresión de esa pelea fueron
tan grande las movilizaciones fueron en
tantas partes del país pues tan
contundente el símbolo del pañuelo es
fantástico en ese sentido y que
obviamente tal vez su desesperación
parece mayor que en otros casos pero
creo que es por esta cuestión de
proporcionalidad en la que no nos en por
agendas propositivas sino por agendas de
negativa a las ampliaciones de derechos
que buscamos nosotros y qué papel juega
la iglesia tanto la católica romana
siendo el papá argentino como las
iglesias evangélicas sin duda jugar
jugar un papel completamente es clave
para el bien derecho argentino no es que
no se les parece algo menor no no es que
moralmente no me esté en contra pero
bueno que la argentina lo disputa y se
mete a fondo en intentar impedirlo es
muy irritante
por qué digo prácticas innegables de
esas iglesias como su inserción
territorial demás terminan siendo
también
las acciones maniobras de manipulación
la aprobación de esta ley de aborto
podría crear un efecto dominó en el
continente recordemos que en la mayoría
de los países menos cuba uruguay y el
guayana el aborto sigue siendo
penalizado espero que sí de hecho sean
2018 algo que como y emocionante es que
se armó digo y tiene una doble emoción
porque el plan del verde en argentina
que viene del pañuelo blanco las células
de marzo de la ola de 3 de mayo es decir
carga con una historia de lucha que se
con que se retomen se convierte en la
contemporaneidad en una nueva consigna
digamos en entiendo una nueva búsqueda
que al mismo tiempo se terminó
expandiendo en américa latina llegando a
una foto que para mí era alucinante es
la de tonos cuando los que se armaron el
pan de los chilenos manero mexicanos
etcétera
una cosa espontánea que ahora y ahora
que sabemos que podemos coordinar la
tiene un potencial inmenso así que
espero que así como en argentina
estamos muy cerca de conectar el derecho
al aborto así lo pueden hacer las
hermanas de la patria como joven
militante y después como joven mujer
política vos sufriste muchos ataques
agravios de todo tipo y muchas veces muy
violentos como aprendiste a lidiar con
esto como que han venido mucho a la
vulnerabilidad como quiero ser fuerte
que ser fuerte pero a la vez soy
vulnerable soy persona entonces es muy
complejo lo que lo que me produce que ni
siquiera se trata de mí yo soy el chivo
expiatorio soy la excusa para aleccionar
un movimiento generacional que me hace
es decir no sé dónde no se trata de que
les caigo mal seguramente también les
caigo mal
y no se estrese a los y ritesh pero en
realidad se trata de que yendo me y
violentando me con esa constancia le
están diciendo me están es un amigo que
está están diciéndole también a todos
está arriba despejados en mi ejemplo
piensan no solo en participar sino en
representar que el precio es mucho más
alto de lo que piensan lo que intento es
no dejar que ellos me marquen de lo que
hablo ellos más
decidan sobre tinta creemos no darles el
gusto de tener que estar hablando de mi
cuerpo de mi vida o lo que sea
yo tengo una agenda tengo compañías de
compañeras y a eso a eso me dedico y
creo que como saben ya puedo tener
éxitos índico
no tienen otra opción que esta son
mientras tanto ok me intentó sostener
desde desde la templanza de las ideas a
veces mortales pero es en la fórmula que
me funciona cuando me funciona muchas
gracias ofelia y gracias a ustedes por
estar con nosotros siguen conectados con
tan 0.4